right let's turn to the war in Ukraine
right now and while there is intense
fighting along the front line in the
donbass region joining us is the defense
and security analyst Professor Michael
Clark good to see you Michael thank you
for coming in so why is this so intense
right now in the Dom bus it's intense
because this is strategically now quite
important the The Liberation of Curson a
couple of weeks ago was the biggest
setback that the Russians had had down
in the south west but now the attention
turns up to the Northeast because this
area from svato to criminal that we've
been talking about for a little while
this main artery the p-66 highway is
really important to to Russian supplies
further south and criminal in particular
is the sort of hinge if the ukrainians
take criminal and they've been attacking
it very intensively now for some time
then they can they can hinge round from
luhanskin to Northern Donetsk they can
begin a big sort of left hook which will
really upset Russian plans and the
Russians know that and they've dug in
ferociously at both fatova and criminal
if they lose that line the Russians
would have to go back to starobilsk
which is about 35 miles further east and
that will really complicate there and
really you put them almost back on where
they started in February so that's why
it's so important because criminal is
the is the key now to opening up or
failing to open up the rest of the
luhansk region and move into the donbass
for the ukrainians and they seem
determined to try to get criminal in the
next couple of weeks we'll see what's
all this about Russia launching cruise
missiles stripped of their nuclear
warheads sounds quite incredible yes the
ministry of Defense have confirmed on
the basis of what they've seen on the
ground that um this is a the NATO knows
this is the Blackjack bomber and the
blackjacks carry this kh-55 air launched
cruise missile which is a nuclear
missile
um the Russians look as if they've taken
the WarHeads off them that they are
using these cruise missiles now without
a warhead just with ballast where the
Warhead would be because they have to
put something in the space to keep the
balance of the missile as it is
um and they're using them so it's it's
inert it has no explosives it's just a
missile and they're using them
apparently almost certainly as a decoy
now that tells us quite a lot first of
all it I mean these are Russia's nuclear
forces these are Central and Putin has
of all the things he's modernized he's
kept the nuclear forces up to date so
there's they're taking missiles out of
the most Central thing in Putin's mind
nuclear missiles they're using them as
drove as as decoys as a drone decoy so
they're not even using them for
explosive purposes they use them as
decoys which shows us two things one is
that the Russians really are running
short of missiles that they can use and
two that Ukrainian air defenses must be
pretty good because they they're having
higher levels of success because the
Russians now need to decoy those
missiles so sending a big cruise missile
it might be a 1980s cruise missile it
was designed in the first came into
service in the status but it's a big and
powerful missile and having to use them
as decoys now shows that the Ukrainian
air defense has really got the Russians
worried goodness right
um Winter's drawing in we know that
ukrainians are suffering now lack of
heat water electricity but with the
conditions changing how will that affect
the fighting yeah these are some images
I mean that image on the right is from
the psalm in 1916. many people would be
familiar with that that remains from the
left is back last week and that's uh the
the Ukrainian Ministry of Defense uh put
that out amongst another image a number
of images as backwards shows you quite a
lot of things tremendous similarity
um trenches don't change very much from
one era to the next you know trenches
are trenches trenches the trenches and
they're full of water and so on and
there's a lot of broken trees and that's
a sign of artillery fire of course all
the trees and nothing but stumps we saw
that in the first world war we see it
around Batman now there's no tree above
about four feet high because they've
just gone the artillery is taking them
all away and the point is that you know
winter for the civilians in Ukraine
started a couple of weeks ago in the
sense that the Russians have been
attacking the electricity winter for the
troops on the ground starts this week
because the weather is changing now in
the next few days between now and the
weekend it is expected to be below zero
for consistently now three or four
degrees below zero from now to the
weekend
and that will freeze the ground three or
four days of consistent Sub-Zero
temperatures means the ground is frozen
and that ground will stay in a normal
winter somewhere between 5 and 10
degrees below if there is a 90 cyclone
in Siberia which doesn't happen every
year but it does happen then it'll go to
20 below or more and that will be
life-threatening and the point is that
in that case people in the trenches some
of them will just freeze to death and
the the difference will favor the
ukrainians because they've got better
equipment they're better organized
they've got better Logistics they get
better food I mean all of the problems
that the Russians have will be magnified
if they get stuck in a really harsh
winter and every infantryman you see
there from the picture on the left every
good infront knows how to look after
their feet because looking after your
feet in the Infantry is fundamental to
what you do trench foot is a you know it
becomes a big problem there are some
cases that already trenchful so they
know how to how to look after themselves
and so in a way the winter War for the
true is beginning this week and we'll
see how they each side copes with it
absolutely fascinating thank you Michael